ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we have
uh an audio only episode for you we're
going to be doing video episodes
on mondays from now on that are going to
be released
uh mondays 9 p.m this one's a little
late
you know this is a big week on our tour
here i'm in new york city doing a show
at the beacon theater we're coming from
dc we've been living on a tour bus
um
but we have a new studio being built
in uh
los angeles california so we're here
with ray
and ray has come over to the hotel and
he's brought his equipment hello
thank you for having me yeah well it was
a necessary thing to have you why cause
the equipment well that's part of it
that seems i mean i feel like people
like me well you insulted my hat it's
not a great hat you insulted you
look i see a hat now you you wear hats
sometimes now people see you in the
videos wearing hats occasionally with
your sunglasses i wear them frequently
they're good hats this is you you have
this hat it's got an old-school mesh hat
but it's not even like a trucker hat
it's the kind of hat you buy at a gift
shop of a golf course when like you
forgot you get to a golf course and you
go oh i forgot my hat i'm afraid to get
in like leopard spots on my head let me
get a hat right and then and you you and
you're flaunting it to me i said oh
what's up with the hat what do you mean
well i'm not flaunting it you came in
and immediately started attacking well
you said this is a cool hat i'm like
well look that was a gift it's a nice
gift someone get it someone gave it to
me it's fine it's a gift
all i said originally was like oh yeah
because that makes sense because it's
not the kind of hat i think you would
wear
are you are you do you are you acting
the way you're acting now like on a
pedestal because you're going to teach a
class at the university of austin
do you know what the university of
austin is i've heard of it barry
weisse's new online school is she
running it oh yeah oh wow
have you no no no no no no
the people that have been canceled from
the uh institut
institutions of higher learning right
are it's like lex friedman and
takezinski the weinsteins
and barry and some of the people that
you're involved oh i mean
nuts
yeah some of the people at the
university of austin like me many do not
right i was not approached about the
university of austin what would you like
to have taught well here's the thing all
the people that i hate hate the
university of austin but what's great
about me is i'm like
kind of
an ally of no one really right they
don't really want me involved in that
either if they offered you one of those
uh honorary degrees yeah would you show
up to accept i want a fellowship
what is a fellow i don't know
that's why i want it
i don't know but i i want more than an
honorary degree i want to be able to
teach a class oh so you want to be a
yeah i believe we can get we can kind of
apply
to be students or be professors to be
students
at the university of austin i'm sure we
could yeah i don't think they're going
to turn our money away
i
wait what do you mean
by the way it
it didn't even dawn on me that there
would be money exchanged
like i didn't even think about the idea
that there would be like
financial i mean this is in case
all i saw on twitter was people sharing
like screen caps going like no we don't
have accreditation we don't have like we
don't actually offer degrees per se well
here's where i will say the the
university system as countries is insane
sure the amount of money it costs to go
to school right how useless a lot of
these degrees are sure and i've talked
uh
you know all you know
ad nauseam about
um
the how corrupt
these uh institutions are in terms of
like the teachers raising their own
salaries administrators raising their
own salaries professors people making a
lot of money uh they're in league with
the government guaranteeing these loans
kids putting themselves in an insane
amount of debt and it and a lot of these
schools not all of them but a lot of
them
everything is pretty one-sided
politically that's pretty sure i mean
the way i see it off top of my head
seems to be like saying like hey the epa
is not great at making sure your water's
not poisoned so just poison buy some
poison water from us i don't think like
he's like oh like his degrees are
useless so like they're not better than
us
it's not an argument to buy your degree
yeah i don't think the university of
austin i don't think it's for people
that want degrees where they can
actually work right i think it's just
people that go we want to pursue truth
it's skankfest for brett weinstein it's
perhaps that it is but it's like people
that are going i wanna it's the
dedicated the mission statement seems to
be it's dedicated to the fearless
pursuit of truth
[Laughter]
that's the mission statement
veritas
so now i think it's all online can can
you get your phone or my phone we gotta
look this up
because
i hate the woke universities which we're
not even supposed to say woke anymore
what do you mean why well we're not
supposed to say them say the word woke
because we're not allowed to say
anything anymore what do you mean why
because today they just came out with
the decree
uh you know one of the chicks from the
view is like you can't say woke anymore
because it's a dog whistle or whatever
who knows
dog whistle it's just like why look
everything is a dog whistle to these
people
so we but i'm saying i'm no friend of
the
blue haired
gender studies well that's more of a
dark whistle what the blue hair
i think blue hair is more of a dog
whistle than woke what is blue hair dog
wrestling you know it's just like that
kind of like you know uh gender fluid i
i'm honest i hate them sure but i think
there's job i think woke is the most
like sterile way i don't care
that's fine that i'm just saying
i'm no friend to these people sure and i
kind of support the university of austin
but it is seemingly a little absurd what
happened to america that i got picked
between like two groups of hucksters
that's always been america i mean it's
always been america what do you what do
you want me to look up here you got your
phone the university of austin okay this
is why the show doesn't work without a
producer
i want to know how to get in and if
we're allowed to get in
and what we can do
okay uh
what starts here changes the world now
let me ask you a question yeah should we
get into the university of austin right
and then start problems immediately oh
yeah and like start claiming
that we
are
non-binary and where we were like
sexually assaulted
oh you mean like as students we started
saying like heather hire
like raped us
well maybe not her because that i don't
know how believable that is brett
weinstein
i don't know who
barry weiss
i don't know i just i think that we you
gotta you gotta start poking around with
not not outright rape accusations sure
but just little by little i was
misgendered
well
like
little by little just you play the game
a little bit just play the game i had a
microaggression done upon me well
they're not playing that game over there
so it's gonna have to be the other side
what do you mean it's gonna we're gonna
have to start accusing people of being
this is what gay
mean like the other side right we're
gonna have to start accusing people at
the university of austin of like trying
to invite us to secret trans parties
okay they're hot like they're
self-hating trans people and they're
having these trans parties and they're
inviting us to them so they can sexually
assault us what if i start slut-shaming
is that like a viable path no that they
you're going the other way like
university of austin is going to be okay
with all that
do you understand what i mean
conservatives are a weird thing because
sometimes they like it when you when
they people [ __ ] but then you know also
you call them [ __ ] we could call them
pig [ __ ] yeah we could start doing we
could start accusing people of being in
a mossad okay you know what go down
there road go down that road yeah you
killed diana we could start getting the
race [ __ ] really crazy we could go like
there could be a lot of like racial
diversity on the campus well i mean like
we could start pushing into hard right
where they're uncomfortable
like to just shape a skull stuff yeah
you start pushing it there right just
see how far they'll go hey
how big is your lie
gerbils what how big is your
the big lie i was trying to do a gerbils
reference okay do that right it's a hard
enough usually hard right i can't do
that on the show that gets three
thousand listens please five eight five
to eight okay
tell us how we can get in here okay
admissions and age undergraduate
admissions
let's see welcome to longhorn nation
what is that no this is not it you're on
the real one hey you're on
ray there's a real
uniform texas a m
like university or or like maybe it's
not texas a m there's a university in
austin
we're not talking about it
the university of texas at austin that
right
we don't mean that get on twitter
go to twitter to the university of
austin on twitter okay
i'm sorry i'm trying to get into barry
weiss's college
it's the university of austin
with lex friedman
and uh
andrew sullivan's on it there's other
people let's go barry weiss first and
then yeah
there's a twitter
dedicated to this new college is barry
white's off twitter what the [ __ ] is
going on here did she block you because
you're fat maybe
the official tweeter were kind of
barrier 56 57 000 followers that make
sense is this barry weiss why look i
don't know what you did what are you
talking about this little guy and this
is you barry weiss
no dude i'm joking i'm trying to fight i
mean are you what are you not fought
juden
you don't follow barry weiss what are
you talking about why wouldn't you why
what's to follow why because you don't
agree with her i don't i follow 400
people i'm sorry i should follow more
people i guess okay i have it right here
okay i have the university of austin
right here up
now
i'm sorry it's on my home page
all right
but i'm trying to find out
i'm trying to find out what's going on
here
austin org
at austin or university of austin it's
been followed by 10 000 people already
here it is ready
we're done waiting for america's
universities to fix themselves so we're
starting a new one
a university dedicated to the pursuit of
truth the fearless pursuit of truth
tyle ferguson heather hunt david mamet
joe lonsdale stephen pinker lex friedman
andrew sullivan
other people larry summers they get a
lot of people pedro
enron
no he does talent here oh okay
what if what if it was just corporate
criminals
like passed out
andy passed out
ken lay's son in parenthesis um but it's
the university of austin
i mean
dave portnoy yeah look why not
you could be the gym teacher it would
just be a funny week to announce that he
was dave fournier
is he too toxic for them now i feel like
he's you know i feel like look i don't
know what happened with him but like i
feel like he's a better person
i trust him more than any of these
people i i probably do as well dave
portnoy you know insider you know you
don't remember this kid uh that used to
work there was a comic this kid named
i'm not gonna say his name he used to be
a comic he quit comedy then he started
working for business insider he
interviewed me a few months ago yeah for
like an hour
and um the profile never came out i
totally forgot about it then he texted
me three days before the pornography
thing came out or like two days and he
said listen
um
uh the reason it never came out of
business insiders they wanted me to run
a hit piece on you right that you were
some like reactionary comedian look i'll
say this i don't like the way they
marketed that story it's crazy
i've never seen that like i mean yeah
people give [ __ ] at the time you see the
times like like like promote a
particular story and get like pay gained
it like it's that's the most trashy
like unrespectable way to like do
anything just like throw it behind the
paywall to me was unconscionable
also when you read the story there was
no crime committed right there there was
no suggestion of any crime committed
yeah there was no significance
yeah that he abused his power in the
workplace there was no suggestion that
he had an inappropriate relationship
with someone that worked for him or that
he had promised someone something
it just seemed very weak
yeah
sure did not seem like it was really
that
you know and i think i didn't pay for
the article so i didn't see it when it
come no but there were screenshots i
didn't pay for it either don't imply
that i paid for it
you would have more money if you went to
the university of austin i agree
portnoy took a lot of eyeballs you're in
the sports world more than me he's takes
a lot of eyeballs away from
people like espn and stuff that you know
you know probably are not happy about
that he's an enemy of the new york media
uh
yeah i mean i can't say it's wrong i
mean yeah it sounds like that was just
logical i mean you know uh
you you think it was like [ __ ] steven
a smith and uh
some of those guys espn i know i just i
don't think it's those guys i think that
they
people don't like disrupters i think
poor noises are destroying i'm a dude
he's he's a loud mouth he trashes he go
like he's not afraid when elon musk
was doing [ __ ] with the whole amc thing
for sure he's going after robin hood
he's going for this i mean he's not
afraid to rattle cages and so
the idea that someone would retaliate
and this
wouldn't surprise me it's just same
thing as like what what we've done and
what i've done
with with podcasting it's like i don't
set out to
you know do anything other than make
people laugh but people end up getting
angry and then the show's done really
well so a lot of these new york media
types hate me too because they're broke
and they don't have anybody following
them and i have all these people
following what i do and i think
portnoy's in a similar
position
i mean look it definitely seems business
insider has done nothing to make me
think it's credible that you know i i i
there's nothing like whether they change
the name for business insider to just
insider where they're like when that
happened
recently their past couple exactly came
out no it was a couple of months ago
they're basically like no we're a
tabloid yeah like inside edition yeah
we're like we're a tabloid
yeah i mean was business insider ever
legit mag i have no idea
yeah the guy that started it is like a
disgraced guy who's banned from
trading oh really he's going at him on
twitter all that yeah i mean it doesn't
look porno is a scrappy guy people want
to see him fight they want to see him in
a corner fighting
and you watch that video of him
michael rappaport was suing him
and over that shirt he made and then the
warrior was giving him [ __ ] he's just
talking [ __ ] to the lawyer you'll give a
[ __ ] he doesn't care he's like he's a
boston guy you know yeah he's got money
yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ] why make the
money if you're not if you can take [ __ ]
from lawyers that's a great point you
know come on down to the university in
austin
will this have a physical campus
uh they they did there was some
screenshot about like how we don't
really necessarily believe in
oh no they they do want physical space
they like the idea of it yeah well you
need a brick and mortar yeah i mean it's
gonna be like a yeah it's extra little
caesars yeah
no it's gonna be like an h r block
yeah i mean
you're gonna need a brick and mortar
sure yeah tax purposes for sure
no there should be like a quad where
people can hang out
look at the alley next to the little
caesar yeah
you're gonna have to have security
because antifa is gonna probably visit
that campus i mean look here's the
reality know the people you mentioned
they all have some money they don't have
endowment money they don't have that so
who's gonna bankroll this it's a great
point i mean prageru
they seem to be bankrolled by like some
kind of you know i mean the mega
churches or whoever i mean i'm not sure
who and also are they even a brick and
mortar situation
i don't think prageru is a real you
but but i'm saying it seems like a more
legitimate step than whatever this is
going to be perhaps but i don't think
dennis breaker is
do you think anyone's going because i
went
nobody's walking into a job interview
going hey i went to prague or you i'm
sure
in certain areas of the bible belgium
the guy who started my school is talking
about how he wanted to contract cover
remember that dennis prager was like i
wanted to get it i was hugging people
and i finally got it now i'm happy to
have it the lord blessed me yeah
sheath underwear folks you know what i
say about sheath underwear the uh the
owner is a uh
a virtuous pedophile
meaning that he's attracted to children
but he's never acted on it and we take
his word for it
it's a man named robert patron
and he served in iraq she's under where
he was allowed to molest children only
if their
parents were had information so that was
like
we deployed his sexuality as a way
to like kind of advance our aims in the
global battlefield against terrorism
robert patron virtuous pedophile the
owner of sheath underwear.com which i
love sheath underwear
it's a great underwear it's like a
bathing suit it's shorts it's underwear
it has a nice pouch for your [ __ ] and
balls your junk
keeps everything perfect from your you
so you're not sweating like a monster
sheath underwear dot com you got to use
the promo code tim to save 20 that
sheath underwear.com use promo code tim
to save 20
and you gotta
you gotta support a virtuous pedophile
because it's it's a great company it's a
guy who's not molesting children
but wants to every minute he's alive and
isn't doing it sheath underwear dot com
promo code tim for 20 off
you know what i love mint mobile
i'm telling you right now there's it's
great
i hate big wireless providers
if we've learned anything it's that
there's always a catch when i first
heard that mint mobile offers premium
wireless service starting at only 15
bucks a month i thought what's the catch
but after speaking with them and using
their servers it all made sense there's
no catch mint mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only by cutting
out retail stores there's no crazy
overhead cost to get passed down to you
in the form of mystery fees and the
worst experience about getting a
wireless provider is going into the
store right you wait a very long time a
lot of people that work there are brain
dead they have an attitude it's always a
problem so the they've cut out the least
fun thing about it
for people looking for extra savings you
know i would go into the sprint store
people just eating tacos and looking at
you the people that are working there
and they're just they were bought by
t-mobile everybody's mean
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 a month all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network
use your own phone with any mobile plan
and keep your same phone number along
with all your existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with your 7-day
money-back guarantee switch to bitmobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month
to get your new wireless plan for just
fifteen dollars a month get the plan
shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com tim dillon that's
mintmobile.com tim dillon cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com tim dillon i love mint
mobile i use it i choose it
i will never lose it
i think it it's something that you have
to
really take in and start and just
forget these big wireless providers
because
a lot of them
don't care about you
and all of a sudden you're just a cog in
the system and it's inconvenient to keep
going to stores
i like the internet because i can do
everything on
line everything's online now you can
have full relationships with people
online marry them and have children with
them and you never have to see them
and mint mobile is beautiful because
they've taken the
the least fun thing about getting a new
wireless provider the brick and mortar
store
it's a little crazy but i'm telling you
right now it's kid i was i i'm
vaccinated what is your feeling on the
booster
uh
look at this point
you know i don't think they waited for
the booster to kill me
in the worst case i understand but like
though at a certain point it's like i
have i i have had it
i have the empty bodies
i'm a little wary of just continuing to
just put covert in you know what i mean
look i mean i don't know it was
indefinite i i totally get that logic
and i'm not like i don't necessarily
agree with the mandates right or
anything like that uh me particularly
i'm not
on the cover of men's health this month
you know so
i might you know uh go one more booster
one more just tied me over for the
winter yeah
booster for the winter
i got to think about it i think i have
the antibodies from actually having it i
don't i don't want the booster i don't
want to keep putting this in my body i
don't know if there's any real downside
to that uh well i don't know either
there isn't either nobody's gonna know
yeah the problem is no one's gonna know
yeah
there's a downside to the young people
getting myocarditis
hardship getting involved a lot of
people get my own cartilages
what are you talking about
that's such a pfizer response hey hey
it's just a guided office hey a lot of
people get mario kart divers shut the
door shut the door
um
yeah but there people are losing their
minds i mean you know i'm backstage
getting ready to go out and do a show in
dc everybody had to show their vax cards
get in
and then these people are coming up to
me going to have your mask on if you're
not in the green room and it's like
something's going on here right
so people are going to get boosters and
still keep their masks on so explain to
me what's going on
when is it just gonna be
mask forever
and boosters forever because i'm not
doing that right and i think most
americans
that are rational people don't want to
do that i think they got six months left
of where i could even like pretend like
six months i'm saying of like look i'm
not saying i'm six months i've been
wearing a mask all the time
i thought you were like they got six
boosters left
if you can't cure me with five more
boosters including this one listen to me
six boosters left that's it i'm saying
this in six months
we're we're gonna be where we're gonna
be it's like we're not gonna fix this
well why aren't we there now uh
there was a lot of resist look these are
all narratives working out right so the
level the cases are not high i don't i
don't look at case numbers but
kind of high in colorado weirdly okay
and then they keep saying like europe's
experiencing more cases than you look at
it's like 200. but here's my thinking
i'm not saying that anyone should you
know i'm not i'm not being skeptical but
it's like you know it's gonna get worse
in the winter it always does
so like the next spring it's gonna thaw
out it's gonna get better and then
that's kind of where we're going to be
in my opinion but that's what we thought
last spring
you know i'm not saying what's going to
change i'm not predicting what's going
to happen i'm saying from my perspective
i understand but we're two cycles of
that line of thinking not working out
well the first cycle was very
contentious and then the second cycle
is it getting less contentious no but
look here's the thing here's the way i
look at it is regardless whether you
agree with a vaccine or not there was a
legitimate reason for them to go
we need a vaccine should we go vaccine
hey we're going to try to push this out
we're going to try
even with the desperation mandate all
right give it a shot see maybe people
will just take it fine
you made your play right now it didn't
work out it's like a movie that failed
it's like you know when john carter came
out back in disney and bomb didn't keep
releasing the trailer for john carter
yeah you know so it's like
worth a shot
i just keep putting the trailer maybe
it'll excite them again right
now what was john carter why did that
bomb so bad it was based on a story
called john carter from mars it was
about a man who
went to mars or came from mars what year
was this 2010 i think yeah it was a real
big bomb for them it was before they
bought the avengers i think so it was
yeah
there's there's part of me though i'm
getting a little sick of it and i don't
think i've got six months left in me no
i i'm saying for me like i've always
been a little more like look i don't
think it's going to poison me there is a
virus like i don't think i'm not con
so i'm just like
but i'm saying i'm saying in six months
here's what i'm saying in six months
i'll start going out like this has got
to stop we're like i'm not i'm not quite
there yet i'm like look because like
he's a thing a lot of people are yelling
at each other
and like if you give if you give them
the benefit of doubt the cec [ __ ] makes
them [ __ ] up you know calls yeah but
like they tried
look i think they're doubling down on
something they know doesn't work
i don't think this is worse i don't
think they know it doesn't work i think
it's like look but it doesn't work it
fades away after a while but it doesn't
work when you get it it does i know you
guys look they keep saying the breakaway
case or breakthrough cases or
but you are like rarer than like you
know that's wrong like you they're not
no some people got it but also everyone
that got it has been vac like a lot of
people a lot of people there are plenty
of them they've switched to narrative
now from breakthrough cases are rare
that they're not rare i don't think they
did that yes they did really yes i don't
know what you want me to do you'll be
getting pitchforks now i'm telling you
in six months i get a pitchfork why do i
need to get a pitchfork now
i mean
i'm trying to be a reasonable guy but
it's it's not reasonable you're sounding
like a crazy person and i'm coming maybe
you're right i'm not of now sounding
like a lunatic i'm saying to you look
we'll fight the government in six months
you want six months to just get in shape
you're like i need a boot i can't do
that six months i can't do it i guess
i've been doing the on the switch i've
been blue in the dance game what is that
they have a game where you hold the joy
con and you just dance around like
follow the motions
actually what is that
it's just are you sitting no i'm
standing i'm moving around you can tell
how you're moving it's called just dance
on the nintendo switch yeah so i'm i'm
spinning around my apartment
well that's dangerous as well sure but
yeah i mean it'll get a little in shape
a little bit yeah and you see you're
just spinning around dancing do you
choose the music
they have popular songs i was dancing to
something it was uh like the weekend
this is what you do instead of the
booster
you don't need the booster you need this
game
and you just dance around your apartment
you shed the pounds they have the the
weird little hoop oh it was a fitness
switch fitness thing i was afraid the
hoop wouldn't you know go around my
stomach because it was like put it like
a hula hoop or something about it you've
always been an interesting fatalist like
you're an interesting fatalist like i
have all these weird like i'm hyper i'm
a hypochondriac i'll get mri's i don't
need like i'm a weirdo like that you do
have an interesting element of and i
respect it and i want to be more like it
the fatalist
will be
sort of
yeah i mean i just i just feel like
things are simpler
a lot of the time like yeah look they'll
they make a big fuss for kennedy when
they want to kill him right and like a
911 no no i don't mean conspiracy
theories right no
you right you're not you don't you're
not a guy that's like panicked about
i mean i should be well sure no no well
that's i agree that's kind of the
question it's like well but the
interesting thing with you is like
you're paying about all the wrong things
too you admit that like you're paying
about like you know a rash when you
should be getting in shape yes i agree
so it's like yeah i i don't worry about
if i'm gonna get cancer i'm gonna get
cancer right that's how i view life yeah
we're gonna go to a doctor
i'm like have them check me out probably
they don't look
people get cancer all the time my mom
got like had cancer she survived but
like five doctors told she didn't have
it and she was persistent that's a good
point you know like i mean what kind of
cancer did she have uh like ovarian
you know my point is like i'm not that i
love i love just the idea of that
because they i've heard that story from
many other people yeah we're literally
it's it's the most demoralizing thing
yeah and you know it's these [ __ ] don't
want to pay they just want them to drop
dead right and like literally like
people like your mother people that i've
met literally have to go and go no i'm
telling you i have cancer i'm bleeding
from places
i'm telling you it's cancer i googled it
myself it's cancer i did years ago i had
a like a scare or whatever because i
thought my balls were lumpy so i went to
a urology first time i went to
my gp
and then he told me first go get a
sologram done so
some woman just rub jelly on me and
start scanning my balls i go to the
urologist he just grabbed my balls and
like they didn't even and i said i got a
sonogram done they said they didn't send
me [ __ ] they just gripped my balls and
uh he said i was just swallowing glands
but for all i know i've had testicular
cancer for 15 years and this is growing
right i tried i went
and i was told i was an idiot
he looked at me like i was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's a good point yeah but do
you know why because none of these
doctors were educated at the university
of austin that's a fair point the their
dudes are gonna change they're blinded
by the woke things are
the long island
[ __ ]
that's that should be the [ __ ] the
theme song one day by
just lex friedman and perry wise hanging
symbols together
blind jordan peterson blind
is he on board or is he an outcast now i
don't think he is on board he's the old
look it's a weird thing he's like the
only one that like he's like the star of
the bunch he went the furthest down the
road the crazy rabbit hole yeah but also
still somehow by far the most
respectable for sure it's like so great
like i mean
he went to a moscow prison wherever it
was and like
it's over well documented but still like
when brett weinstein's [ __ ] you know
like chilling he's like you know and he
backs not whatever he's doing it's just
it's just like yeah i mean i listen to
jordan any day
jordan seems to be the most
intellectually
uh sound yeah of that crew
i guess harris is a neuroscientist but i
just he was always you know but there is
a problem in academia right so how do
you deal with it because everybody in
academia has lost their mind you get
look accusing everyone's talking about
like student loan forgiveness yeah which
like i'm not going to go and debate i do
the people on twitter who go like well i
paid off my student loans what the [ __ ]
like you know i'm just screwed you also
you you got scrooge or everyone else you
get screwed that's the worst response
like anything like this you have to like
you can't just like wipe out 70 grand or
someone's debt and the guy who paid it
off gets [ __ ] like this it's just not
society can't work especially if the
people whose debt you're wiping off are
actually wealthy people whereas that
guy's a blue-collar guy sure that that
either paid his own debt back or didn't
go to college and got a job as a
carpenter yeah
that being said
so maybe you do that well i don't know
we figured that out but what really
needs to happen is to stop student loans
at all right because that's it's just
like health insurance
that's what causes this like this uh
spigot of like price going up because
like it's like
even now everyone's aware i mean i guess
less kids are probably going to college
or who knows though because and like
either way it's like well i guess i'll
just when you're not when you're 19 or
18 you're just a furry you're going to
look i mean
excuse me i'll be one of the lucky ones
well you go by the time i get out of
here i'm going to have a great job
back everyone's telling me it's not the
case but you're like well these people
are morons i mean if you don't go to
harvard or mit it's like pointless right
uh you i mean you'll get a job
you you'll need a college degree to work
at burger king for some reason but they
these crazy jobs require college
education but the only ones who actually
make real money now or like ivy you know
top level ivy league stuff so you just
wipe out these student loans you got to
get rid of the system
that allows these universities to build
these kids out of money right which is
the sallie mae yeah [ __ ] it's it's an
endless spigot that like is your there's
no incentive to like keep it competitive
if they had to worry about what people
could actually afford
they would have to keep it in line and
why these campuses need i didn't go away
at school i wouldn't like to
uh
it seems nice but that being said like
how about you just go to a state school
local community colleges like why do we
need to go away well have this
experience it's a false experience
yeah who some people say occasionally
he's racist
made a point that college is just an iq
test so instead of your employer giving
you an iq test they're saying where did
you go to college this was ann coulter's
point the other day and she was talking
on andrew sullivan's thing and what she
was basically saying is you endure the
four years of college uh because they've
outlawed the ability of an employer to
give you an iq test i don't know if
that's true or not i mean it's pretty
reductive and no it's not i mean there
might be some truth to it but like yeah
but here's my overall point my overall
point is this like ignore the specifics
per se of that example sure i do believe
that there doesn't there seems to be
like there should be a way for an
employer to decide if they want to
employ you that doesn't involve you
waving a piece of paper
that says you went somewhere for four
years
and i don't know what it is i don't know
if it's an iq test i don't know what it
is but there should be some measure of
your ability because that's what
colleges college is job security for
people you you should be able to say hey
yeah i'm confident smart i'll work hard
i'm this i'm that i think most people
who go to college it depends depends on
what you study like engineering yeah you
need to go right
and and and science type stuff sure but
a lot of stuff where like you could do
it like programmers or like you know
post-production like video stuff and
like and film stuff a lot of people like
me who've done or worse at it they're
actually like they're not the people who
have like
what about the university of austin
college of crypto like it's one of the
colleges with the university that's one
that's like being a doctor so yeah you
should go to college for that's the
college of crypto it's like nft
university
why
don't you think because i fully believe
that if i went to college right i would
have had a completely different life
if i went away to if i want to wait a
college it's one of the biggest regrets
well let's be real yeah you know we know
how your 20s went why don't you discount
the idea that you would have just like
partied your way out of the first year
of college i don't think that i would
have been as influenced and as uh you
know
i don't think i would have started doing
coke with a bunch of mortgage guys if i
was going to a liberal arts school yeah
when you were 13. yeah but i would do it
on and off but like a lot of the heavy
periods of time you're doing it with
other people that are doing it and i'm
not saying that it's impossible that
that would have happened but like had i
been influenced by a bunch of people
that were just like we smoke weed we do
this we do that this is what we do we
drink
i think a college experience i would
have come out of the closet sooner
i wouldn't be a comedian
i wouldn't be funny right because i
wouldn't have had to be yeah i would
have probably learned how to live
earlier if i learned how to live are you
discounting all of this
uh are you saying that if you had gone
away to college you don't think you
would be a different man i might have on
a different path i might have gotten
better women earlier on i don't know uh
well you've gotten some lovely women i
have look i'm doing fine so i'm not
complaining the woman that you went that
you went to the we're not gonna rehash
the story but when you went
to the flanders duck in long island and
you brought that woman arby's and she
kept calling her roommate carl right and
the girl she was a girl yeah she kept
calling her female roommate called the
writing joke they had i think i think
they were off-duty prostitutes right
which
i think they were on duty prostitutes
for money
for arby's yes well that's listen yeah
the point is this you don't think that
you would have had
a better i don't know if it's better
but it would have been different well
the point i was making was i look back
and go i probably would have [ __ ]
lazied my way out of the first year of
college just like it basically did i
went to like local like community
college for years and like barely went
to class what do you mean you went for
years i went for like the topic for like
a bunch of years i did too i'd go in and
out of nasa right and you didn't like it
why didn't you you're sitting here i
enjoy parts i remember you look my legal
knowledge a lot of it comes from i i i
have a paralegal uh the question so many
people have for you is that you're so
intelligent right but
you never liked schooling it's very
interesting to find someone as smart as
you that never liked schooling here's
what it is i'm surprised i know like i
i'm smart i know how smart i'm not
uh i'm smart enough to be bored by the
beginning of a class
and not smart enough to not need to pay
attention to like
throughout the class right like oh this
is boring and i tune out right and then
like and there's some people who like
yeah when the test comes like yeah i'm a
math genius i'm not that guy i'm like oh
i should have paid attention like
two-thirds of the way through but it's
even bigger than that because you never
felt it's a pattern i have well you just
never fell in love with the institutions
of learning like you i i i i was very
skeptical of professors i i if i didn't
so weird because
you've made me out to be this right-wing
lunatic but like no it happened when yes
you have when
you say that you were skeptical of
professors
why because they're teaching at a
community college yeah it's an arc well
i agree with you it's the archetype of
person that would become a professor
right you know and and you know at a
community college
uh you know i like i mean i was always
i've had some of the worst i've been
wanting my dad to say like those who can
do and those who can't teach it's a hack
thing but you know it's like it's not a
hack it's true it's true but i mean i
had a public like i mean we had one
class called i forget what it was called
it was cool it was like a communications
class it was like a speech class right
and the professor's name was like
professor ghoulianello
and she was just like he was like she
was just some italian and she would come
in with like you know those boots those
long island boots that like they go up
to your knees and you can scrunch them
down
they're weird they look like witch hats
those brushes
and she would walk in every day and
she'd be like
her whole thing would she be like she'd
be like and if you place your eyes i
will know
like she would just spend like 10
minutes
threatening the class about what would
happen she would just tell stories she'd
be like and this girl
she plagiarized the whole thing and she
thought i would know
well i knew
and this was the caliber of person you
would get
teaching at community college a high
school teacher uh it was an english
teacher very very fat guy yeah and he
used to rest his like uh hands his
little hands on his big fat stomach yeah
and he
a community college teacher and he was
telling for no reason i don't know why
he brought up like this girl tried to
uh you know
failed the final and she offered me
sexual favors and i had to tell her no
what what is going on
why are you telling us yeah
um he wants he wants other people oh
yeah he's put he's planting the seed
he's putting it out there yeah
yeah no
i i just i was never excited by i think
part of it was my sexuality i felt like
if i went to college i would be forced
to confront who i was instead of being
able to just kind of like
make a lot of money in the private world
and lie my way right through life which
was the plan up until i turned 25 and i
said over an hour what like what you
realize this is i can't imagine i don't
think but i could have been a lot of
different things i don't that's not true
i believe so you don't think so you
could become different things but this
is the most raw version of you perhaps
like uh like i could be this is me i
could be less fat but i'm basically who
i'm supposed to be that's true
you know it's like i'm not like yeah you
could have like all the other versions
would have been like false avatars or
whatever like you in a business
environment or you in an academic
environment perhaps i just like to play
around with the ideas of you know life
going another way yeah look i mean the
past is the past and uh
is it
is
is it or is everything available at the
university of austin
i just by the way is all this because
rogan just moved to austin
why is it the university of austin
what is this craziness by the way let's
address that for a minute
what in god's name is this i know lonzo
lives there and friedman might and wrote
like what is this
why are we constantly jerking off austin
musk is also there and they're trying to
get on that train okay yes that's kind
of what it does seem that way
musk's got a lot of money people are
trying to that's a good point they're
seeing how somehow this relates to what
he's doing kids who look i'm assuming
that tesla hires people sometimes i have
mit right rit's also a good school
things like that wait until sometimes
wait till musk hires no one from the
university of austin well my point is
yeah so but there's going to be a class
of people yeah who don't do that well in
school in high school they know their
parents look
tesla's musk is there you send me to the
university of austin yeah i spent a
couple of years networking meeting these
guys at bars right doing coconut gas
teacher with them i get a connection
you know
there's a lot of ways of skidding this
calf right right yeah
ah yeah i just play around with the idea
that if i had gone to college i would
have had maybe a little bit of a
different life you never you never do
that you never look back and go what
could have been
look i think about i i don't what i'm
not a regret driven person
no i shouldn't like you could argue i
i'm the biggest candidate of you know
why regret
i don't believe you're the biggest
candidate of regrets
okay that's this crazy thing to say
but let's for a minute speculate
think about an alternative life yeah
what what describe it uh visualize it
you know look i i i applied the sunni
purchase for the film program okay but
it was hard i didn't realize how it was
more competitive in nyu i think it was a
film program that seems insane but
there's like with less people there's
less spots you know
um
but let's walk it out the point is but
they they did offer like you can go to a
regular school you're like we'll accept
you into the school because i had to go
like an extra interview observatory and
you said no i think look i want to do so
[ __ ] you so i went to hofstra for a year
for film
bad bad bad news so
your whole thing is why don't you stay
home but staying home is horrible
usually it wasn't great have a job
around no it wasn't great i i think
about that
here's why this is let me let me let me
break it down for you in long island
this is why you can't live at home your
parents want you to fail right this is
the reality your parents in long island
are deeply invested in creating an
environment that makes it more likely
that you will fail right truly i wasn't
allowed to go my dad's car insurance
because i wanted to have a signed risk
yeah 500 a month that's crazy they want
you to die and fail
listen
if i asked
if
i asked to take like uh a car to the
library to print something after school
by hand would be like you're gonna get
in that car and you're gonna kill
someone they're gonna sue they're gonna
take the house they're gonna like
there's there's just this idea that
leaving your
uh home
is essential because then your parents
who've spent their entire lives just
trying to destroy you knowingly or
unknowingly can't affect you as much
right
that's the way i look at it i agree look
i mean i i i think my parents are less
uh had it in for me less than yours but
like i don't think they helped you
they banned well
sure
and uh i mean i don't think they hurt i
don't think heard you i don't think they
were
like i i've heard no evidence that they
were hurting you but i don't over
protective in a lot of ways but uh
there was i was kept in a bubble to a
certain extent i believe in santa's way
too way late of an age i'm just saying
from what i know about your history it
could have went better sure it could
have went better
look maybe i was shooting you know a
little
if i went away to school i wouldn't have
had to have a car and sit in traffic on
the way to hempstead every day that's
right uh yeah so i probably wouldn't
have like i mean the first year of
school at hofstra i spent a lot of time
just going to the video library they had
this weird little room with like four 13
inch tvs with the combo
and i would watch anime most of my first
year of school
smoking weed on the top level of the
national community college
i'm sorry the the uh the roosevelt field
mall the top level of their parking
structure with a kid named kenny and
another kid named buns yeah and then we
would get the ranch one chicken and
cheese right amazing i was amazed
instead of going to the class at suffolk
i would go to costco and eat the food
court yes i mean you eat the whole food
i love chicken chicken bacon
this is what i mean about
those who are our comfort zones yeah
that was your comfort costco was your
comfort zone sure that's where you were
home right you felt like you were home
when you ate that chicken bank when you
walked into costco without a family
without anyone to feed without any type
of list of groceries to get and you sat
down in the middle of the day and ate a
chicken bake you were home don't forget
like you have to like
show your id no i had a membership yeah
actually i didn't even but i would just
beeline until the exit when people are
watching and they go
i'm just going to the food court and
they were just like i would just like
brush past them yeah so i was what is
the costco chicken bake
uh it's it's like it's like a pastry
like a hot pocket with chicken like a
chicken pot pie in a hot pocket kind of
but what i mean about this is this is
not the college experience you see what
i mean yeah me getting high
on the
at the top level of a mall parking
structure and you
eating a chicken bake at costco
we're not growing in anything socially
intellectually spiritually i mean i was
listening to the audio books at the time
don't
i had such regret i had a friend i had a
best friend once named joe clark we're
not that friendly anymore we talked when
i was living in palm springs we chatted
briefly
and i wasn't like his brother died
tragically in a car accident i wasn't
really there for him but like i came out
of the closet he kind of wasn't there
for me like we were just not you just
grow apart right we have here behind
this door
it's joe
but
what my point was that he went from
nassau community college to cornell
which was a good step it's a big step
yeah and i went into the mortgage
industry and i had such pangs of regret
and i felt so insecure right that he was
at cornell and i
was a [ __ ] loser
that he was able to now now let's be
honest
i think i think you know it's i think
i've evened it out quite a bit and then
some yeah but and then some let's see
let's be honest
he's he's just a lawyer
you know what i mean [ __ ] joker i [ __ ]
him he's just a lawyer and i i and i
know the vast majority of the staff at
the university of austin
that being said i still love dr i'd like
to be close with him more but
she's an interesting little guy but the
point is that
didn't you ever feel
inferior
because you didn't go to school no i
always had a uh
over-inflated perhaps sense of like i'll
get i would listen i would be like
cutting class at the costco but
listening to the wealth of nations on
audiobook
so it's like you know that's this is why
you're fascinating okay let's get let's
almost delve into this yeah because this
is truly fascinating right it's amazing
it's it's almost like if there was a
character that summed up the decline of
the american empire okay
you're in a costco that you shouldn't be
in
you're not feeding a family
you're listening to the wealth of
nations audiobook
which probably pertains to something
you're learning
and you're interested in things you're
interested in the why this all works the
way it does right why does this 10
gallon jar in mayonnaise how does this
work what is it what's the markup
division of labor all of that now you
yet don't apply that knowledge it's so
interesting to me that's the fascinating
thing about you i always had grandiose
but you're brilliantly funny thank you
and i i here's a part of the problem i
always had grandiose like people when i
was making movies i i i have a few
failed feature-length films and people
go why'd you make a short movie it's
like ah i don't i i can't sell a short
film now you to be fair youtube wasn't
really around back then so like now it
seemed common sense yeah make it a
little short when were you making them
uh right on the iraq war but it was
around no a [ __ ] you do get like oh
506. okay which is the kind of one of
those kind of certainly wrapped up
it just missed a youtube train i mean
there was like something called adam
films you could have done stuff but i i
felt
to be critical of myself i felt like i
was too good to make short films or it
just didn't appeal to me so i'm trying
to make i'm trying to wrangle people i'm
not paying with no money and like maxing
on a couple credit cards to make like a
two like an hour and a half movie which
is insanely
even if everything goes well then it's
even going to be good but the logistics
are even getting it done like so that's
the kind of thing i did a lot i had
these grandiose ideas instead of just
putting the work in
and like you know and learning over time
like you know i'm reading the world of
nations instead of like you know going
to economics class i'm i'm [ __ ] you
know it's like i did get my [ __ ]
together at one point and doing
paralegal stuff and stuff if you had
graduated i got into stony brook i went
there for a semester interesting and
then i just stopped going to class to
become a friend
suny purchase yeah i feel like yeah i
agree what is the version of you that
you think would have been a filmmaker
um
if things just went a little what do you
mean like
like i i
think of myself and i say
i could say the version of me that's
successful in business
is uh
not a happy version of me sure but it's
a version of me that i can
i could approximate like i could draw
lines around it go that's what it would
kind of look and feel like what is the
version of you that's that
like went the film rude i tried to right
i mean like you mean like went to film
school
i just did like i went to hofstra i was
he's a part of the problem with me
i'm really bad at like little things yes
like
showing up on time to meet with your
advisor to get classes before they close
out i didn't do it
my freshman year and then like you know
before freshman year and then like in my
life you know it was funny yeah but so
basically by the time i met my advisor
and i got around to it like they keep
telling keep going i'm like fire it'll
be fine and like and like i can finally
meet with him big idea guy well yeah i
finally meet with him he's like well you
didn't do any film classes your first
year right you probably won't do it your
second year maybe your third year and
i'm like well [ __ ] this right uh when i
went to the nassau community college
advisor and he would sit down and he'd
i'd like i'm like i'd like this class
because that's full yeah you guys you
have to go to this class you have to go
to that class why was it full because
you didn't show up on time
i didn't show up on time yeah because i
was out there doing drugs yeah yeah same
idea so it's like you know i never
learned self-discipline in a cohesive
way
do you think people like us had we
learned self-discipline it would have
hindered the type of things that
we do like if i had learned
self-discipline i was able to discipline
myself yeah would i have done would i
have been what i am no no no right you
your entire existence right now correct
and which is a great existence yeah
it's fine it's not that great well i
have material things yes right i love
some material things you'll get some
yeah but then you'll realize they don't
matter i know i won't realize that yeah
the point is
the point is like but whatever you have
is like
it's based on your kind of whirling
dervish kind of like you're you're
always floating around you you're
mercurial you're changing the dime it's
what makes you funny it's part what's
part of what it's part of the package
but if you were sitting around like you
know and like you know no we got like
you're like you're spontaneous you're
you can be erratic these are the things
that may like i sit there uh
and i look at compared me to you and
like and i'm not like a big [ __ ] or
anything but i'll [ __ ] consider going
like oh you're freaking me if i do this
i'm am i gonna get canceled i don't
actually think it in my head but there
is that less i'm i like to think of
myself as a crazy man and
start yelling at someone i do start
yelling at people at stores
uh i i i try to get in the fight
sometimes but like i'm not as like
free
yeah as you for instance right
i am more free and i don't yell at
people at stores usually i don't think
there's i've yelled at a few people at
stores but there's not much i don't mean
like clerks i mean like other customers
right no no one's accused but see even
then when you're making that distinction
you're afraid of getting cancelled
by some marxist who's like you're you're
yelling at the proletariat or whatever
that and you're like uh no i'm
actually yelling at others i started
screaming an old woman once because she
was giving [ __ ] to the guy at the post
office yeah and i just started saying
i started screaming shut the [ __ ] and
she's like yeah yeah she's on her side
i'm like no you you [ __ ] [ __ ] stop
choking him and i started
yeah what is this scene out of the
grapes of wrath who's this for
our one time i saw this cop beating the
goddess this is all that i've gotten
between them i don't think i sound great
yelling like you should get cancer with
old woman no what i'm saying is like
when i'm just elderly i just like to
play around with the idea of like
perhaps it could have went differently
that's all sure
things could have gone differently yeah
but i got lucy my girlfriend's great
i'm happy and i told you i get the
podcast i think you should move to
austin things are we're making i'm
making moves to do that
i've said nothing but positive things
sure look i've never
you were like the ambassador for austin
i love it yeah i like the two
restaurants and the university of
university do they have uh like a pizza
hut
yes they have all that here's the thing
you would kind of fit in sure because
there's a lot homeless there
that's a big part of it but more than
just aesthetically right
you could get into the life that even it
would be harder for me to get into of
like
hunting and woodworking oh i would like
to have they actually have that there oh
you can do it okay i thought i don't
even really do that there no you you if
you live out where i'm telling you to
live 20 minutes out like one minute
i'm telling you the hunting and the
crash
maybe yeah i don't get involved but the
point is like we should fish sometime no
maybe
go to florida yeah i'm gonna do that in
texas i don't like lakes sure what are
we doing but my point is like there is a
life
that you that you might like
yeah no i look i like the outdoors or
the idea of it i'm an eagle scout that's
true yeah i have a fishing rod badge or
woodworking mirror bit i'm stacked with
mirror badges so it's like i just don't
think this i don't think we should
dismiss this university velocity because
maybe
there's a world where we go back to
college and become the things we were
meant to be where barry weiss accepts us
into her bosom
embraces us can you picture a moment
yeah
where
me and you were getting diplomas and
barry weiss is softly crying
looking at us because she's so proud
right
what what what are we majoring in who
cares do you think they're gonna ask
that
do you think that's what this is about
we're majoring in the fearless pursuit
of truth have you not paid attention it
was like a youtube seminar
david dobrik's teaching how to [ __ ]
not rape
your philosophy classes and saying make
sure you cut clips and add subtitles
and put them on twitter right listen
it's a philosophy subtitling class
so when i added up what i pay every
month for cable plus at premium channels
on top of what i pay for on-demand
streaming services i was shocked
man it was like a lot of money hundreds
of dollars i wanted to trim my tv and
streaming budget but what would that
mean giving up a bunch of shows channels
movies i love nope not with philo
this is a really cool thing phylo was
created by tv lovers for tv lovers
here's what i get for just 25 a month 60
premium tv channels a massive on-demand
library of top-tier beloved shows and
movies to watch anytime i want unlimited
dvr the best and biggest in the industry
that lets me save up shows for a year i
can stream filo on up to three devices
at the same time file it was super easy
to set up with no hassles or contracts
and what you're paying up for tv and
streaming brutal
filo gives me totally better tv
experience for 25 dollars a month so
what filo does
for anybody that's wondering is it
really goes and grabs
60 premium channels
a ton of streaming content
a lot of the hot shows almost all of
them probably all of them
wraps it all together okay
and you pay like 25 a month
instead of spending hundreds of dollars
a month
so i asked my friends at filo if i could
offer you guys a special deal to try
filo and they said of course so i got
you 25 off your first two months go to
philo.tv tim dillon
that's philo.tv
tim dillon it's a much better way
okay
to do this so you do not have to spend
hundreds of dollars all these life hacks
are
really important if you don't want to
spend a crazy amount of money
you just switch to filo yeah i love it
yeah much much better it's great
it you know it's like filo dough you
know filo dough is a very thin dough
actually i don't know that though well
filo dough is a thin dough that you make
like the croissants and stuff it's very
flaky pastry but this is a network a
service where you're getting all the
streaming channels all the streaming
content and the premium channels you're
paying 25 a month as opposed to paying
several hundred dollars a month i was
saving i was spending like 175 i mean it
was stupid crazy yeah it was stupid yeah
but now you're streaming to file them
i'm saving a lot of money now and you
can stream it on three devices at once
so who's losing
uh not me not you but the
big media is losing that's right but
you're not losing the murdocks are
losing not me they're losing i love
games
don't you
i love games
i am the versus game and we're gonna do
with the tim dillon boy here's the deal
versus is a game
and it is a fun game and what it allows
you to do is make predictions
i assume many of you know the answer to
these questions and right now there's an
opportunity to make money on your
knowledge look no further than versus
game
it's an app a lot of people i know are
talking about it a lot of them use it it
lets you win money for being right
imagine a social media feed where every
video is a question which is two
possible answers you can play these
questions for real money against other
people you can vote on each poll for
free but you can also play the any of
the game anywhere from one dollar to a
hundred dollars per question there's no
odds it's just one verse one you against
someone else you can bet on anything
literally anything versus will even find
someone out there to match your better
your money back
swaggy boy q is asking whether nfl
player henry rugg's dewey sentence
resulting in a death
will have his prison sentence announced
by tomorrow so you can ask anything you
could say what kind of shirt is kyle
rittenhouse going to wear to court you
can even make your own games about
anything on any topic that people will
bet on you get a cut so the more people
play the more you get paid you got to do
something that has a you know an
immediate kind of answer right or like
within a certain period of time right
there are 7 million users they've given
over 16 million dollars in prizes right
you can you can bet on anything and when
the answer is jazlane maxwell gonna be
convicted like
and when the answer happens you either
win or lose and people are really
winning and winning a lot of money
and i'm excited about it because i like
making predictions i've made a lot of
really predictions that have come true
when i said music will be a big jiggling
ass and then lizzo performed in front of
a big jiggling ass at the american music
awards i really make predictions and
these predictions come true more often
than not it's scary how accurate i am
you kind of predicted covet remember you
and giannis yeah my predictions are
scarily accurate okay scarily and that's
why i think i can make a lot of money
with the versus game i just have to find
the right games and you can bet with me
or bet against me but
versus game is a way to earn money by
being correct and i'm never wrong
so i feel like i'm gonna end up being
the jeff bezos of the versus game we're
gonna come up with some cool games to
get people involved but it's easy
so
pull out your phone and go to the app
store and download versus game right now
and play my bats the versus game one
word with no space they'll even give you
five dollars towards your first bet with
the overcoat tim that's
v-e-r-s-u-s-g-a-m-e
offer code t-i-m for five dollars
towards your first bet that versus game
offer code tim t-i-m
um
you know we could do like when
like when will whitney cummings be found
in a bathtub
like a font like you know what i mean
like fun yes yes
alex warren from tick tock is asking if
netflix will renew the high pass show
for a second season by december 20th
well it hasn't even premiered right
but that's a you know people can ask any
things
you know
radar online is asking whether tourist
spelling and dean mcdermott will
announce a divorce by november 30th
you can play any game you want someone's
private life it's a game
the future of someone's family it's a
game
everything's fair game on the versus app
it's fun it's fun
they're not going to know about it
it's fine
will someone's cancer come back
it's on the versus game
it's fun it's a fun game
you know
will the american system of government
collapse within 36 months
you can win money with that
you might win money
you might win a few bucks with the
versus game and we're gonna do some
games what do you bet what about you
maybe people will start asking will ben
leave the show well ben quit well yeah
the the immediate one is like will ben
kill tim uh will ben's wife kill tim
neither one of you gonna probably kill
me but you know
uh
it'll be interesting to see what
you know what what uh youtube have
cooked up
so i mean just download the versus game
it's very important you know
there's seven million people doing this
it's backed by luminaries such as mark
pincus kevin hart william
jeffrey katzenberg mark burnett josh
richards from sway house do they write
josh richards from high pass he's from
sway house people are idiots
the winklevoss twins and peter thiel
look at that wow what a crew we know the
winklevosses yes they were so lovely in
that episode they gave one-word answers
for an hour and then me and jake paul
talked about ethereum
uh which was a lot of fun actually
and peter thiel who started palantir and
you know they're on the up and up
so uh
you know versus game
it's a good game
the horrors of the world
you can bet on them now
instead of trying to fix them or believe
that your elected representatives may
one day change the laws to make them
less likely to happen you can bet on
things happening
you know
when will we be required to have another
coveted booster so we could go outside
how soon will the secret prison start
at what point will the camp roll out
happen and who will go in first
these are all fun games to play on the
versus app right until the phone is
smacked out of your hand by the military
loading you onto a truck
anyway
versus game go download it i wanted to
do the uh the guys uh gofundme too that
reached out
yes the guy who had the aneurysm
yeah
okay so can we talk about that yeah you
have it
yep i got it right here so uh this guy
reached out and uh he wanted to pay for
an ad but no we're
you know he's lucky his brother's luck
he had symptoms of an aneurysm he's able
to get it drained that's very rare yeah
it was his cousin it's very rare that
you have symptoms of something like that
before it becomes a you know kind of a
fatal event
a brain aneurysm and uh so the guy's 28
years old yeah so he said uh you know we
don't have any copy this guy's name is
joshua
uh nothing specific to mention other
than we need all the help we can get the
final building will likely be hundreds
of thousands after this [ __ ] i'm
telling you right now i'm in the
healthcare system is so [ __ ] satanic
in this country
that as much as i hate these lefty
[ __ ] weirdos that make you wear the
masks it's like i i i just believe that
it's such an evil to have a healthcare
system that just completely destroys
your life because you had a blood vessel
pop in your brain right i mean it's just
it's like disgusting but that's where
we're gonna help this guy out tell tell
so i'll put a link in the description
obviously but no this is this what's
this guy's name kyle rittenhouse
this guy's name is nick nick
and we're trying to help uh with this
assistance here we're trying to raise
about 60 dollars here it would be good
if you guys could donate to this this
guy's a good dude he had symptoms of a
brain aneurysm they said he had a
massive one mm-hmm and they were able to
he went in for surgery right mm-hmm can
you read it ben yep so we are raising
money for nick's medical bills and cost
of living while he's not able to work on
the morning of october 27th he suffered
severe symptoms as a sudden increase in
body temperature vomiting severe
headaches he's only halfway through his
battle a recovery period estimated to
last two weeks in the hospital at times
painful especially in the beginning he
has health insurance but will still be
responsible for a hefty percentage of
his treatment and stay at the hospital
in addition the cost of living and
support his family is not something that
can be put on pause so he has kids he
has a he has a family he's a whole thing
so how do we help this guy i'm going to
donate money and i want everybody go
fund me it's a public gofundme okay so
what is the gofundme because i want
everybody that's listening to this show
if you can
donate some money to this guy like let's
really show this guy that we can help
you out i will pin the comment in the
youtube channel and if you're listening
on apple or spotify it'll be in the
description at the at the top above the
description so you can't miss it yeah
and they want you to roast him it says
here
uh which i i don't know how you exactly
right this is what i we're not doing
that this is you know it's like we're
trying to help
you know what i mean it's like i
understand what people want you know
it's never enough is it you know well
here laughter is the best medicine yeah
is it well then don't won't give the
money
how about that
no i'm not going to roast on command
here we're trying to help jesus christ
roast them i don't know what the funny
angle is here about a guy having a brain
injury
you know i'm sure there is one but i i
i'm not finding it
i'm trying to help
i love that why don't you roast them hey
pig why don't you dance hey we're gonna
raise a little more money now okay how
about that
let's tug at some heartstrings what do
you let me sell okay
my brain works
i'll sell
anyway i you know i want to help this
guy we're going to help we're going to
raise money for him okay i don't know
anything how am i going to roast him i
don't know anything about him
what am i going to say oh this guy's
vessels don't work cool
rose comedy's dumb it's for dummies
okay
smarten up
please
had enough
you try to help people all you do is get
bitten everybody just smacks in the face
it's never enough you know
he sent me three emails where he he says
it would mean the world to him to be
tossed into flames by tim for a moment
so by the way i wonder if this guy's
just a dick and wants me to just like
roast this guy who had a brain aneurysm
is this guy like a dick or is he trying
to help the guy no he sent the receipts
on facebook and stuff to prove he's real
and stuff
it's good no i believe he's real um
i don't see what there's anything to
roast here
i i don't know what to do
brilliant aneurysm more like
like what what do we do here
you know
this is him i mean here's a picture of
him if you want to you got any got any
quick roasts on him let me see i mean
the guys looks young about as far as the
laptop can go right there dude he looks
like a kid he's in his 20s
god he looks like a young guy
man oh he's got a kid no i'm not in the
mood for the roasting folks
i'm not in the mood
got my own problems
roast you guys thinking a hospital bed
roast them no
help them give them [ __ ] money
the guy's name is kyle rittenhouse
he was experiencing
flu-like symptoms and a rising body
temperature so he bought a gun with a
stimulus check and headed to kenosha
wisconsin
now he's in all kinds of trouble
gofundme kyle rittenhouse but they
raised a lot of money for the written
house defense right
yes i believe it was uh wasn't it owen
troyer that was raising money for the
guys
was it happens or people were maybe
raising money for perhaps i forget
there's several ones that could have
been
[Music]
hey folks january 21st huntington new
york i'll be at the paramount theater
coming back to long island 7 p.m
on january 23rd i'll be in red bank new
jersey at the count basie theater 7 p.m
how great is this artist pre-sale
wednesday november 10th 2021 at 10 a.m
password fake biz this is the best way
to get the cheapest tickets pre-sale
wednesday
uh 11 10 20 21 uh 10 a.m password fake
biz not case sensitive and the on sale
is friday november 12 2021 at 10 a.m
thank you
but my point is this
i was never i've never walked
across the stage right and got a diploma
i didn't i i got kicked out of high
school uh by catholic high school
because you said you're going to blow up
a woman's uterus yeah i mean it was said
jess of course but you know it was taken
it was rancher columbus i did it i you
know i went to my graduation high school
but i'm not i'm not that doesn't count
oh i didn't go back high school
graduation i know you were thrown out
but i went to public school after that
and they they all the kids like people
like me because i knew how to build
mystery like who was this guy coming in
here in the middle of senior year what
happened and i i i i teased it and uh
what'd you say
i i i was very coy about it it was very
much like you know uh i didn't say i
wasn't i may have threatened a woman no
like what is it i didn't leave with that
i may have threatened i don't remember
what i said i do remember some of the
cooler people
uh
kind of like they took me to lunch one
day at the pizza shop they drove me to
the pizza shop and they blasted rap
music and then
and we had a nice dinner but i don't
think i made a great impression at the
at the pizza lunch because like
that didn't keep going on i think
someone's like yeah cold and sick that
day so i got his spot but the point is
but i wasn't just sitting there alone i
mean i did sit alone in the cafeteria on
purpose and uh but they were all saying
why don't you come to graduation like i
barely went to the school but i could
have gone but i didn't and i do wonder
i've never held a diploma in my hand
should we remake the movie lae where we
play every part yes you know yeah i mean
where either me or you yeah is playing
every part of the movie l.i.e
i mean
with with uh brian cox can we get brian
cox to play so his partners
he's good he was the kid
that wasn't pulled down though yes it
was really looking like he was the main
kid he was a main kid oh wow look it up
ray
mr film buff i mean i saw that movie
when it was disturbing
what was disturbing about it it just had
a very like it had a very i mean there
was some child [ __ ] going on right
yeah but it wasn't even like i agree
that the premise is completely
disturbing about like his pedophile
driving around but like to me
like
i don't know this accident statistics
like in the beginning i feel like it
kills everybody the little guy it was an
eerie blink movie it was you know is
there a win
on the island expressway there's lanes
going west there's lanes going east yeah
and there's lanes going straight to hell
the character of the father was amazing
going to jail yeah everything was uh
disturbing about it i agree it was a
vibe to that movie it was a very it
almost felt like they were promoting
pedophilia
i mean
did it feel like that no i mean i'm not
saying i'm not saying it's a pedophile
movie i'm just saying it didn't feel
like uh it felt it almost this is what
it did feel like it felt like saying
parents in long island are so bad you
might as well just choose a pedophile
that's literally what it was saying
that's someone who spent like five
minutes in long island and went you know
what the best thing that happened to
these kids would be a pedophile right
that is paul daniel by the way i know i
didn't realize but
i'm just imagining a a spring
years from now yeah when there's no more
covered right okay in six months and
heather hyng is handing you a diploma
yeah and christina hoff summers and
andrew sullivan or katie herzog or
lex friedman or david mammoth whatever
david yeah he's involved too is he he's
involved lawrence summers isn't like
blind gary guys involved they're all
involved it's gonna be big where did
mamma get into this this guy this guy's
got a career what's he doing no because
you you you you always underestimate how
far the other side's gone
you don't understand how crazy the other
side is the woke yes yeah but he's a
legitimate filmmaker yeah but that
doesn't exist anymore they're not
letting anyone make legitimacy i guess
he's another movie in a while i didn't
love heist
my point is that you carry water
for the last i didn't i just didn't
realize i don't mean the real left i
mean like these liberal power seeking
lunatics yeah i didn't i just i just
thought you still had a career as my
point
what i'm saying is that
the university of austin is not without
its problems
okay
but
in terms of
this is your new home
look i am fully
committed to uh
accepting a adjunct professional role
uh yeah perhaps you know what if i
split off yeah if i join the university
of austin yeah and i open up something
called the university of san antonio and
i take like hardcore alt-right people
like david damagu like owen benjamin
hardcore hardcore richard spencer like
the hardest of the hard yeah
that's uh it was a move it was a schism
in the university of austin we went our
own way
do you call the university of austin at
san antonio yes
tell people where they can support what
you do we have the comp podcast it's
really uh it's it's really hitting its
stride this year it's uh phenomenal me
and lucy steiner we're just killing it
every week he's definitely tuned in for
that on uh youtube or wherever we get
podcast comp uh we also have a patreon i
think ben will put the link in the
description
so you can get an extra episode every
week for that and support the com pocket
so just check those out uh raycomp on
twitter and instagram check them all out
please also
um
we're at the vegan theater
yes and we sold out yeah
but i'm very excited to be part of this
very fun we're gonna do a podcast
at the end of the stand up it's gonna be
phenomenal it i'm excited i don't know i
think it always is but it'll be good we
make magic happen it'll be exciting what
if we don't stop talking like what if we
do three or four hours like should we
just do it until people walk out
i mean see that you want to talk about
something that would kind of be amazing
i mean there's a problem we're living in
a fomo culture
so with like how many of these people
would just stay because they're afraid
of missing something great
that's a good point and we just don't
give it to them ever yeah we just keep
there's nothing great coming
what if we we get to the point where
we're just
we do the 30 minutes but where the text
not working
the text like the tech oh right the
podcast isn't working
[Applause]
so
it was an abortion that i i couldn't pay
for
yeah like i think there's something
funny to the idea of just ben like
running around losing his mind and of
course we just play you know we know
that we can get the tech working if we
we want but we don't can we get a fake
gun but they don't know it's fake
no
that's a problem it would be amazing if
we both killed ourselves
at the end of the show
it would be amazing
it would be
i mean what if we both killed ourselves
and left all of our money
to the university of austin it's an
endowment it's an endowment yeah
i mean what if
what if i just put a gun in my mouth
okay and i was like i'm leaving all my
money and you can barely hear me
it's an endowment for the university of
austin
very wise in the highest spending yeah
barry weiss will know how to spend all
this money
goodbye and then i just blew my brains
out
you be remembered
i mean you would you would edge out
budge wire i think sure you'd be the new
budge wire will we have we're not going
to have to get me on live tv though no
no one will care
you can't get anyone to care about
anything in this country
you blow your own brains out at the
beacon theater you can't even get
anything yeah
um and we're not gonna have a guest
what kind of guests do you think i don't
know oh you mean for the podcast yeah be
hilarious you just have a guest can we
can we get
um like muffy powder aston or
new york socialite yeah gonna come on
probably uh
do we get a criminal
we can can we get rabble gorievich
here's what might be funny could we get
curtis sliwa i would i think we probably
could there's something funny about
curtis sliva he would be amazing did he
get any votes
he was a republican candidate that's
maybe not
i love that article in the daily
election when he showed up with his cat
yeah and then he was just screaming like
there was a problem he said arrest me
arrest me
i want him to be mayor
yeah and then the other guy eric adams
who like clearly doesn't live in the
city was like driving on the sidewalk
it's absurd
i i wonder who we could uh yeah i could
get chris lee i think we could get
curtis oh yeah
that's totally doable yeah he just walks
on stage with his cat can you ask him do
they have a like can he come dressed as
a guardian angel though
i think he dresses like that all the
time yeah did you see that commercial he
had with like the homeless guy no but
he's like the homeless guy is sobbing
and he's going like oh because he's
outside some like mental institutions
yeah going like they're not keeping
track of these other people they're
letting them out we got putting people
back in here and there's like homeless
guy shows up with no shirt and then like
i have a bandana on his head and he
starts going like yeah man
like whatever like and screaming and
goes it's not he's just crying and
cursing was like kind of puts his hands
on your shoulder it's not your fault
it's not your fault like you know
they should they we should be taking
care of you but the absurd thing is like
they make this into a commercial i see
on jeopardy stern talk told me about
this he said it was amazing this is the
most insane thing i've ever seen in my
life and he's like critically what cares
about the homeless you put him in the
campaign
i mean
i just i'm amazed
i'm amazed at a guy who spent a good
amount of his career inventing fake
crimes
by the way did he do that oh chrissy
would invented fake crimes what do you
mean he rescued people from pretend
crimes really yes he would set up fake
crimes and then say that the guardian
angels rescue someone it was a complete
fraud oh wow no you could look it up get
caught like dude oh yeah oh wow he's
admitted he's like i was younger oh [ __ ]
oh yeah that was his end game with that
to just he wanted to be like [ __ ] the
gotham city like he wanted to be batman
i don't know the guy wanted to be like
some like the avenger running around new
york city like
he was psychotic wow uh
you gonna talk about that
i don't think he's gonna come on i think
he would i don't think he will he just
lost the mayor whether what else is
going on
he's not moving into these people are so
crazy
okay
like you know the like uh what's the
guy's name on success you think he's
gonna be president son
yeah so connor from succession the
nothing child yeah who's like thinks
he's gonna be present people like
caitlyn jenner and people are courtesy
they're that crazy
they're like nuts no yeah they are but
curtis leewar is nowhere near caitlyn
general level he's got nothing going on
that's true caitlyn has a lot more of a
chance yeah yeah i'm saying like she
wouldn't do what she went to a imagine
by the way no no but imagine hearing
that like an advisor sitting down with
courtesy we're going you are nowhere
near caitlyn jenner like we can't even
get here regardless of the kardashian
thing
olympic uh hero
no but i mean
in terms of electability caitlyn's much
higher oh yeah much higher and that's
gotta be amazing to hear right like
caitlyn is much higher than you yeah you
have no chance
yeah who are we going with caitlyn
jenner uh all day right over you you
[ __ ] loser
yeah i mean curtis slew up if you do
do you think you'd ever run
yeah 100
yeah i think so i i i think i'll run i
wonder
i wonder if it's delusions of grandeur
but i would definitely uh i could see
myself as being in
uh another crap
well it definitely is delusions of
graduation
but that's a funny thing like if mean
you moved like a little shitty city like
portland or something maybe not
portland's two left wing but like
somewhere we could kind of you're the
mayor of cleveland i yeah we probably
could yeah that's the shitty thing
you probably could that's how low rent
america is right now they're like no one
wants to be the mayor of cleveland right
it's the worst job there's a few
restaurants who are okay like the
probably get to meet lebron james
yeah maybe there's nothing cool about
being the mayor of cleveland no that
much that's what's kind of my problems
huge
nobody wants that gig
so that's how you know america is on its
way out is that being a mayor of one of
our major cities now the perks do not
outweigh the problems no at all you'd
much rather work at any other company
that being said uh
you gotta work it that's why you look
there's definitely businesses in
cleveland that want you to look the
other way not a lot really not a lot and
let me tell you this this is why all the
people doing these jobs now are
criminally insane
like when you look at like marjorie
taylor green they're like there's
nothing cool about being a congressman
anymore no one gives you can't get
anything done who gives a [ __ ] the grift
is dead the grift is over so the people
that are doing it are lunatics right
people are like why are these lunatics
i'm like there's nothing left right
the carcass has been skinned i think i
could make a
like my own version of the squad
yeah
i think you could do anything i i i i i
haven't what if you and four really fat
white guys
were like out progressive the squad the
guts like if if
you like four fat like three fat
midwestern guys became the new squad and
you were to the left of like ilhan omar
but our catchphrase is yeah we've got
guts yeah like we've got guts you go no
military
no police federal amendment banning the
military banning police i'd be like i'm
sick of these [ __ ] and you point the
ilhano home on ashley i'm sick of these
[ __ ] with their half measures we got
guts stop stealing our surplus value
it's just you and three other guys and
it's just like uh two tons of fun
this squad what would they call you guys
the
the squawk
the squish the squish
the squad is being pressured by the
squish
the squish is for midwestern gentlemen
all about 450 pounds who are incredibly
progressive they've endorsed things like
banning the military and all police
while the squad thinks that a lot of
what the squish wants to do is
unrealistic the squish says that the
squad is just playing old dirty politics
you could be the spokesman for the
squish yeah yeah
this is the rancher the squish
you say thin people aren't attacked
and fat people
the existence of thin people is an
attack on fat people i'm all about
inclusiveness inclusivity inclusivity
yeah this squish
like you see like aoc being like
i think we've had a lot of productive
dialogue with the squish
i think the squish the squish will not
compromise with the squad let me be
clear about that
we will not be countdown we will not be
wailing yeah
she's like i understand where the squish
comes from but i think politically
this squish has not accomplished
anything listen to me the squad is
politically irrelevant they're out of
touch
and they're going to be
under the boot of the squish
squish just for
fat lord ass
this is
communism now we're kind of saying we
gotta tell you how to replace each other
yeah we're like new fat people we keep
dying
yes people keep dropping
people
because we're all like we're all like
crooked coke heads who were fat so it
was just
like rob four times like yeah communism
now you just started screaming
i was beat red screaming sweating into a
microphone the morbidly obese anarchist
known as the squish
you
you you're like you're trying to direct
it
like
get them into traffic like thomas
jefferson made hitler look like a lap
dog
the squish have endorsed removing all
monuments from all federal buildings
immediately let's burn this flag
there's a campaign
of you outside of a jimmy john's burning
a flag
let burns you call you fascist pigs
i mean it's a it's a rude yeah it's a
root look honestly
if i told you 30 years ago that some
congress squad explained that to you oh
he's laughing out of the verb absolutely
no the squish is going to happen the
squish could happen
and you know like the new york post will
run headlines squash the squish
i just think hey i just think it could
happen
go to the university of austin
sign up start your life start your life
it's gonna be good
good night